lien noble un imbroglio avec monsieur
losique jeu pour la pour y demander sa
taille ce que je veux faire cependant
c'est louise il écoute et là oui on va
fondre célébrer le 40e faudrait que tout
le monde fasse partie de la solution
si vous me voyez dans ce point question
de ce qui se passe présentement c'est
pas un changement de cap
ça faisait que moi je veux bien qu'on
puisse conserver le ffm
mais il faut qu'il y ait des changements
à l'intérieur alors de façon
diplomatique le maire qui envoie comme
message au président et au grand patron
du festival des films du monde un des
changements on en veut si vous voulez
avoir notre appui il faut savoir pour la
petite histoire que la ville de montréal
la sodec téléfilm canada ont retiré leur
appui financier au festival des films du
monde de montréal qui donc continue
parce que le grand patron veut que ça
continue je vais parler à quelques
minutes
demain c'est la grande première de son
festival qui dure trente neuvième année
et on revient avec nathalie petrowski
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe
serge losique deux mois bonsoir monsieur
losique
bonsoir pas plus
monsieur losique votre ténacité
légendaire pas besoin de le dire à
personne tout le monde le sait à
montréal partout sans subvention pour
vous parler de film ne vous inquiétez
pas mais sans subvention
combien de temps encore vous pouvez
durée avec votre festival des films du
monde de montréal que vous tenez à bout
de bras bah vous comprenez je vais pas
parler de subventions la création
artistique a toujours été lié dix ans à
l'effort de l'individu ou du créateur
s'est séparé si on parle aujourd'hui dix
ans de subvention de jouer pas parlé
parce que les gens ne vient pas parler
des subventions ils veulent voir des
films
notre rôle est d'amener le meilleur film
du monde ici à montréal on se fixe et
cette mission là et on a poursuit et on
sera fidèle jusqu'au bout
mais justement mais c'est ce que je vous
pose comme question vous dit que les
montréalais les québécois et les
canadiens veulent voir de très bons
films
vienne venait beaucoup à montréal pour
ça dans les années en fin des années 80
et 90 là vous avez de la difficulté à
boucler vos budgets
bref à ce que le festival n'a pas une
durée de vie limitée sans subvention
c'est parler aux cinéphiles qui vous
écoutent messieurs losique
bah justement tous les festivals tous
les grands festivals que ce soit cannes
berlin venise et ces traces ont
subventionné parce qu'on expose en même
temps la grande culture
cinématographique mais chez nous c'est
un peu différent ce n'est pas deux jours
d année etc
mais ce fait rien on peut vivre avec ça
et quand vous dites qu'il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui venaient ici même
aujourd'hui je râle à que voulez vous on
a le plus grand vous est le plus grand
producteur quand même et qui a fait cher
aussi le feu sous les 1 français c'est
un grand monsieur l'un des plus grands
producteurs au monde alors il fera même
une leçon de cinéma ici parce que notre
rôle est justement d'amener la qualité
et les qualités a toujours été là on n'a
rien qu'à voir tous les films de
premières comme première oeuvre
c'est là on va découvrir vraiment les
futures vedettes s'est demandé pourquoi
mais monsieur je vous promets l'enjeu va
passer à autre chose mais s'il vous
plaît répondez moi là pourquoi vous avez
été oui dans votre esprit là donnez moi
votre version pourquoi vous avez été
lâché par tout le monde c'est pas
exagérer vous avez été oui là je suis
par tout le monde la sodec téléfilm la
ville de morat et c'est oui mais nous on
a fondé le festival avant le cdec et a
vanté les films je veux même pas
mentionné ses intentions voulait poser
des questions nous on fait notre travail
c'est tout ok je logique 469 film est ce
que je me trompe cette année oui bon
vous a raison et puis on a eu beaucoup
de difficultés
allez choisir parce qu'on aurait sur
juste à montréal 2404 film ça veut dire
que les gens le profession à l'extérieur
et partout à travers le monde prend le
cristal de montréal au sérieux donc
quantité exemple un quantité ça c'est
sûr que qu'est la qualité et la qualité
aussi
et la qualité donc par exemple de nemak
5,6 exemple qu'on devrait aller voir là
des films incontournables
ben vous comprenez vous moisés vous me
posez une question délicate
mc on vous dit je suis patron du
festival dix ans du conseil
d'administration même si patrice alone
in quinzaine choisir des films j'ai pas
droit de dire il est parfaite elle
tellement fait rire mais meilleur que
les autres comme vous si vous êtes des
enfants peut pas dire c'est enfin un
meilleur que l'on aurait bien joué très
bien vous allez ok je vais me poser la
question dit fernando mais c'est un film
iranien qui a été largement
subventionnée par le régime iranien sur
le prophète l'enfance du prophète
5 comment on doit percevoir ça c'est un
c pour la qualité cinématographique du
film ou parce que c'est très
controversée en iran les des gens qui
disent non celle ci s'est rallié au
régime c'est pas c'est pas du cinéma
ben n'exigeant pas il faut d'abord le
vin voile le film vous savez nul n'est
prophète en son pays mais majid majidi a
déjà eu trois graf et des amériques ici
même à montréal et c'est le cinéaste le
plus populaire à travers le monde ils
ont d'autres gras cinéaste mais il a
allié sous la qualité est ce qu'on
appelle le grand public elle ce ça la
force de magie de magie et quand vous
dites prophète
il ne s'agit pas ici de prophète il
s'agit du monde prie slam parce que le
nez avant le dernier prophète d'abord né
alors de l'âge d'un an 13 ans donc
n'était pas prophète il devenu beaucoup
plus tard dans les années 30 quand on ne
les prend pas mais c'est un grand
cinéaste qu'il est subventionné par le
régime
vous savez même le plus
film français à être qui s'appelle
napoléon est subventionné par les nazis
et qui était actionnaire de cette
compagnie c'était golf lui même et
ensuite il a utilisé vous savez le coup
et bien sûr si en plus complexes ne lève
pas avoir d'idée le cinéma les cinéastes
et les artistes ne subisse ne choisit
jamais le régime et le subissent mais là
doit dépasser les régimes et la
politique
monsieur logique donc demain soirée
d'ouverture avec ce film iranien il
rageux lydie plein plein plein plein
film est ce qu'il y aura puis je vous
laisse là dessus est ce qu'il y aura une
40e édition l'an projet bat toujours et
même beaucoup
au delà de 40e édition chez losique
merci c'est tout le temps qu'on a un bon
festival à vous elle est une habituée du
festival des films du monde de montréal
l'habitude de tous les festivals du film
nathalie petrowski
bonsoir bon mélange pas d'abord ils
lâchent pas vous l'avez retrouvé son
dernier souffle jusqu'à son dernier
souffle
qu'est ce qui est arrivé au festival des
films du monde de montréal je me
souviens d'un fin des années 80 90
c'était le festival et grands venus des
ouais mais ça a commencé en fait bon
c'est toronto et est un peu la première
contre je pense delà du déclin du
festival de montréal faut dire que celui
de toronto à 40 ans cette année
donc il est né en 76 un an avant le ffm
et ça allait très mal au début à toronto
il n'était pas capable d'avoir personne
parce que tout le monde allait à
montréal et puis à un moment donné base
ils se sont un peu pris en main puis on
dit qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire à
partir de 80 2 83 ils ont commencé à
faire des hommages à des cinéastes à
martin scorsese et avoir un métier tout
à coup hollywood a découvert qu'ils
existaient et ont aussi découvert que on
pouvait les petits parce que ya le
cinéma américain les groupes block
buster et son mais aussi du très bon
cinéma américain alors c'est devenu une
espèce de tremplin pour tous les films
pré oscars ils ont construit ça au fil
des ans alors un moment donné c'est vrai
il est montréal c'était la grosse était
le gros festivals et ils ont commencé à
être un peu dans l'ombre de toronto et
serge losique aurait dû peut-être réagir
à ce moment là il l'a pas fait et il a
il a traversé toutes sortes de tempête
il ya eu le rapport ces corps il ya eu
le rapport lampron après ça il ya eu le
festival de spectra en 2006 on lui a
enlevé des subventions pour faire un
autre festival
il a tenus envers et contre tous il est
encore là et a déjà en 2006 on lui avait
enlevé des subventions ça a pris
quelques années avant qu'on lui remette
et puis bon ça recommence et l'année
passif mais clairement la sodec téléfilm
la ville de montréal vous avez entendu
le maire dire j'y serai demain parce que
dany laferrière il faut dire préside le
jury
oui donc j'y serai par amitié cas par
différents s'adonner laferrière mais si
monsieur losique veut ravoir l'argent
draka des changements autrement dit on
espère peut-être qu'il n'y a pas l'air
de quelqu'un qui veut quitter oui mais
monsieur logique vraiment est un entêté
et c'est aussi comme ça c'est vrai qu'il
a tenus ce festival à bout de bras
pendant 40 ans pendant 39 ans et ses
tresses et son festival à la différence
par exemple à toronto c'était une équipe
et puis les équipes ont changé alors
alors que monsieur losique et rester en
selle est resté le capitaine et le
président du conseil d'administration
alors un moment donné ça devient une
espèce de presse de tyran vous y vit
quand même super sympathique ce monsieur
là mais et je veux dire il n'a pas
vraiment laissé entrer de l'air de l'air
neuf des nouvelles générations et s'est
toujours entouré de la même bande avec
danièle cauchard danièle cauchard est
partie elle n'est plus là mais là encore
un petit peu la voix des faits mais
participent à la sélection à leurs yeux
tout ça effectivement il faut un vent de
fraîcheur quand on me dit notre village
qui aura 469 film irlandais film we
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre la
qualité de suffisent qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que et c'est vrai moi
l'année dernière pour la première fois
sa façade 10 de nombreuses années que
j'étais que je ne couvraient plus la
compétition cette année puis le bon je
me suis dit je vais aller voir parce que
c est ce que c'est vrai que c'est si
pour x ah non pas du tout mais ce sont
les films sont de qualité et la raison
mais ce sont évidemment des films
d'illustrés inconnus on est à une époque
où on veut de la célébrité ou on veut du
film américain où on veut de la vedette
américaine donc déjà il est à contre
courant ça c'est quoi alors alors
évidemment ça c'est pas toujours très
attirant mais les films sont de qualité
le problème aussi c'est que son
rayonnement à l'international oui avec
les avec les gouvernements avec les
diplomaties ça va très bien mais sur la
carte internationale des festivals son
festival a vraiment perdu du luxe c'est
clair c'est sérieux ça il veut pas le
reconnaître vous allez à berlin où aller
car nous on n'a pas pu montréal
c'est sûr que au départ même au départ
il ya eu toujours eu ce problème il y
avait berlin avec anne y'avait toronto
il n'avait pas toujours la première
sélection ça veut pas
il avait des mauvais films mais là c'est
sûr qu'il en a perdu aucune at-elle
petrowski y aura-t-il et je vous laisse
deux secondes de karim 40e édition vous
croyez où il va avoir une 40e édition je
suis sûr enfin je pense
et puis il ya de l'espoir vous lirez la
presse demain peut-être bérigaud qu'il
ya de l'espoir et voilà tout le monde
est content
merci le faisait très chaud